a very good morning to you there are new
concerns the final stage of the
government's roadmap out of lockdown on
june the 21st could be under threat
it comes after cases of the india
variant of covid19 in england
doubled in the last week now hospitality
leaders have told sky news they fear
more businesses
could go bust if they aren't allowed to
fully open next month
our political correspondent joe pike
reports
in less than a month theaters should be
full again
restaurants at capacity with social
distancing scrapped
but with restrictions due to be lifted
covert cases
are on the rise and the final step in
boris johnson's road map
is now in doubt i think it is really
really
just on the cusp at the moment and all
because the indian variant is spreading
the latest estimates are that more than
half
and potentially as many as three
quarters
of all new cases are now of this variant
it's the arts entertainment sport and
hospitality sectors
that are desperate for stage four of
england's route out of lockdown
to go ahead next month on time because
for now
theaters concert halls sports venues and
restaurants are not
at full capacity and that means many of
them are not profitable
with the table service and social
distancing which is the biggest
challenge that we have out there
is there there is no viability um
there are very few breaking even and
what is your message to the government
we need to open on the 21st it's key
it's very very important
the government needs to understand that
economically but we also need to
understand that we need to open safely
and we believe as an industry we can do
that
but in bolton england's worst affected
area some are concerned
i think everything needs to be short
apart from the few things because we
need that
but there's so many things that's open
and so many things like work and
everything they should put
restrictions i think but just local
restrictions rather than
you know like nationwide or whatever i
wouldn't say impose like a
local lockdown but maybe some more like
tighter like restrictions could probably
help
people don't really care but which is
quite upsetting to see
for now reopening plans continue while
those in government argue
will need to see the data before we're
sure of the date
joe pike sky news in london's west end
now the latest coronavirus data shows
there have been 3542
new cases in the last 24 hours that's
the highest since march the 30th
10 more deaths have been reported which
means the total number of people who've
died within 28 days of a positive test
is now 127 758.
meanwhile another 236 119 people have
had their first vaccination
427 458 have had their second
so just over 24 million people in the uk
have now had
both doses and let's talk to the
business secretary quasi quartet who
joins us now good to see you this
morning look
when we look at the india variance and
we look at the cases rising to the
highest level since the end of march
how concerned is the government how
concerned
i think we're very uh attentive to the
data
and we don't want to proceed with the
roadmap without considering
uh all the information that we have i
think that the numbers
of uh of cases uh is a matter of concern
but what does give me some confidence is
the fact that the vaccine
seems to be working and as your report
said we've had millions i think 60
million
jabs have been administered something
like 24 million
have received both jabs and i think the
effectiveness of the vaccine
is what uh i think is what can give us
some confidence that we can reopen on
the 21st of june
yeah but i mean the problem seems to be
doesn't it that of course i mean 24
million people having both jabs
is not enough and there are some vaccine
hesitancy certainly in some of the cases
we're seeing hospitalized
from the the india variant we might it
be
sensible to delay things until that that
double
vaccination figure is considerably
higher
well as you know stephen people are
being vaccinated uh all
every day and those numbers are going up
uh considerably
and also the other thing that's very
helpful and encouraging
is the fact that the numbers of
hospitalizations and the number of
fatalities as well is considerably lower
than it was
uh even just two months ago so
obviously there's lots of facts that we
have to consider i
as business secretary i'm very committed
to try
to reopen on the 21st of june i can't
guarantee that
and as i've said we're looking at the
data every day
i mean look as dominic cummings laid out
the other day as he said there's a
choice between locking
down early or letting the virus spread
now his implication was that we didn't
lock down early enough
when it came to the kent variant and it
spread like wildfire now there is
you know it's not about scaremongering
here it is a very legitimate concern
that the india variant could
spread like wildfire um you know across
those who are not vaccinated for
whatever reason i mean do you think the
prime minister could
and government as a whole the collective
cabinet responsibility could
air on the on the side of caution this
time right now
stephen as i've said we're looking at
the data uh today's the
28th of may um it's impossible for
anyone to know what the situation will
be like in a week or two weeks time
and as far as i'm concerned we'll be
looking at the data we've said
repeatedly that we won't make a final
decision about the 21st of june
until the 14th of june a week before the
the established date so uh i can't
guarantee
one thing or the other now i think we
just have to look at the data we've got
to be patient we've got to be very
vigilant
people also have to uh be sensible and
absorb uh
observe uh all the guidelines in terms
of face
mask wearing social distancing
and we can't make any uh call one way or
the other
today unfortunately well no but i mean
obviously you're
well aware more than most about the
pressures particularly from small
businesses
at the moment who are saying it's
absolutely essential that they open
on the 21st and and obviously these
businesses to
to get staff re-hired to get things up
and running to get supplies in
particularly in hospitality
um you know they're gonna want as much
notice as as possible now i appreciate
it puts you in a very it puts a whole
government in a
in a very difficult position you want
some people wanting answers now you're
saying you want to leave the data
until as late as possible how do you win
here
it's a very difficult situation as you
know the whole point about the road map
was that it would give
five-week intervals uh by which we could
gradually reopen
the economy and the roadmap was set out
in february
and we were very careful about the
future dates and the whole point about
the five weeks
uh stephen was that we would look at the
data the prime minister said very
clearly
that during those five weeks we would
look and see how
hospitalization rates were affected how
infection rates
uh were moving uh and what the degree of
the demand the challenge was the safety
there's always a risk
element here and so the hospitality
leaders
business leaders i've spoken to are very
clear they they find it frustrating they
want to get
open and run up and running again but
they do understand that we have to do it
in a safe way and we have to look
at the science scientific evidence we
have to look at the data
and that we shouldn't be rushing uh to
quick
uh and easy conclusions and that's what
we're doing that's what we're avoiding
we're actually looking at the data
we're trying to do this in a very safe
measured way
and as i've said on the 14th of june we
will have a decision
uh one way or the other as to whether we
can reopen on the 21st
uh look everybody understands you can't
please all the people all the time
whatever is decided there are going to
be people who are unhappy
with the decision is it fair to say that
you are looking at all
options here because there's there's
going to be
certainly a number of businesses that
would say if the india variant is
prevalent in
certain hot spots certain parts of the
country
why can't they be as unfortunate
as it would be for them can't they be
locked down while the rest of the
country is allowed to reopen is that
something government is actively
considering
looking at uh all options but what i
can't do
i wish i could do this but on the 28th
of may as it that is today
i can't tell you what the indian variant
will look like on the 21st of june
i mean forgive me forgive me i mean with
that question that question i'm not
asking you to i'm asking you to
to answer whether or not you know
something like that could be a
possibility to try and keep as many
people as possible happy
all i would say to that is uh repeat
what i've said before
we're looking at the data we want to
reopen on the 21st of june
and we're trying to to get to that
outcome but
if the data says suggest that it would
be unsafe to do that
we may well follow that we would follow
that
okay look can i ask you about care homes
obviously it's
been a big topic of discussion i mean
matt hancock yesterday
saying he he didn't lie about that
situation he didn't mislead anyone but
obviously there was
wanting to get people tested out of
hospital and into care homes but there
was a you know testing issue at the time
which meant it wasn't always possible
but but the result of that was
devastating was it wrong to say
i mean they used that phrase about
having a protective ring about care
homes
i mean that in effect wasn't right was
it
i think what matt uh stressed very
carefully yesterday was that he was
absolutely focused right from the start
of the pandemic on saving people's lives
he was in a difficult situation as the
health secretary
in a pandemic the like of which we
hadn't seen for a hundred years
he was under huge pressure and as a
cabinet colleague i know that he worked
really hard and very few people if
anyone worked
as hard as he did and he was very
committed to saving lives
now he said uh what he said i fully uh
believe him but we'll have an inquiry
and that will iron out all these these
facts
um sticking to the to the business theme
if i can i know you're very keen to get
small businesses as they
try to fight back from all of this
you're very keen for them to to go
greener to cut their carbon emissions
now they've got so many pressures on
them at the moment as far as i can see
you're not providing any extra money to
help them out
to to become greener so i mean what
realistically can you expect them to do
what's really been surprising to me and
i've been really impressed by
is the fact that lots and lots of
businesses want to go greener not only
larger businesses
who are committing to the un uh race to
zero in large numbers
uh but also smaller businesses are
really wanting to learn more
about what they can do uh to fight
against climate change and actually i'm
i'm
feeling and seeing a huge responsiveness
from small business leaders people as
you say who are under
a lot of pressure at the moment but they
really want to help uh on the green
agenda and that's why
uh we're launching this campaign i think
it's something that people
are really responding to look can we
just finish off with i mean i i know
you know you will not be someone who
agrees with the sentiment
that migrants are a poison are you but
those were the words
of of the hungarian prime minister
victor obama who's
visiting the uk and seeing the prime
minister today
the labour party says entertaining him
when we've seen what he says
on these issues and some of it is is
horrendous
it absolutely undermines the values that
the uk
stands for and holds dear so why is that
meeting taking place
so you'll know uh stephen that as a
leader
as politicians people in cabinet people
in responsibility
we have to speak to all sorts of people
all sorts of leaders
across the world whose values we don't
necessarily share
i think victor orban's views on migrants
are things that i would not endorse in
any way having said that
i think that we have to engage with the
eu he's an eu leader
hungary is an eu country we were part of
the eu
and in this post-brexit world i think
it's absolutely right
for us to be building bilateral
relations with countries in the former
eu i think it's
completely reasonable to do that and
not to do so i think would be
irresponsible so it's a diplomatic
relationship that we we want to develop
uh we want to talk to european leaders
and i think it's absolutely right
that the prime minister does that
minister it's good to talk to you this
morning thank you
thank you thank you if you're thinking
about that
green business initiative that the
minister mentioned
today uh don't forget you can see loads
of stuff about uh
climate on the daily climate show here
on sky news half past six and a half
past nine every week day
with anna jones
now still to come on sky news breakfast
uk hospitality is warning more
businesses
will fail if lockdown restrictions
aren't eased in june they'll talk to us
at half past seven this morning
we'll discuss the scientific evidence
behind the warning that the big
re-openings in june hangs in the balance
with dr zabada hack from the independent
sage group that's at five past eight
and at twenty past eight we're in los
angeles as prince harry releases his
latest tv show
on mental health
now a charity is making a new appeal for
potential stem cell donors to mark
world blood cancer day dkms tries to
find people to give blood and bone
marrow
which is used to treat patients but it
says a number of people signing up
has fallen by 50 percent during the
pandemic
jemima walker reports
like other three-year-olds ryan brissett
likes riding his bike and playing
football
but unlike most children his age he has
a rare and
life-threatening blood disease called
cgd
he's had to have multiple stays in
hospital
we stayed in for six weeks this year um
in one turn he's been on several
antifungals central antibiotics
um he's consistently taking medication
scars ryan could be totally cured by a
blood stem cell transplant
but his mixed ethnicity makes it
incredibly hard to find a donor
there's only 20 percent of blacks of
asians that register
um to we work with dkms
um and the rest is called asian people
donating um
obviously ryan needs a multi-racial
donor
um which hasn't come up yet a leading
charity says there are 2
000 people every year waiting for a
life-saving stem cell donation
but since the pandemic there's been a 50
drop in people signing up to donate
the charity is calling on certain groups
to urgently come forward and register
young men um because they they tend to
be they tend to make the best donors in
terms of
certain clinical reasons and partly due
to the
the number of stem cells that they're
able to generate and donate but also
there's a great need for ethnic
community donors because
when um a patient from an ethnic
minority needs
needs a stem cell transplant they've got
a much lower chance of finding a donor
25 year old sam schmidt is a registered
donor
last year he was matched with someone
saving the life of a stranger in canada
it was amazing to find out i was
someone's match it
brings a real sense of responsibility
and also sort of worthiness you're
sitting there and you're going wow like
that i'm potentially their only chance
so it's a real
opportunity to help somebody
sam stresses the procedure of donating
is painless
and only lasts a few hours but it can
give a fresh chance at life to someone
like ryan
do you use the hands no i'm wavy
jemima walker sky news
also making the news for you this
morning officials in tokyo have
restarted the olympic torch relay
despite a state of emergency being
extended in the city because of the
pandemic
an official announcement is expected
later and would mean restrictions could
be in place until
just before the start of the games in
july
president biden has ordered u.s
intelligence officials to widen their
investigation into the original outbreak
of covid19
in china he's asked for a report within
90 days and he said he'll make the
findings public
now if you're in california then you
could be in for a bit of money they're
offering prizes worth more than 116
million dollars
to persuade people to get the
coronavirus vaccine
anyone who enters uh who gets the jab i
should say is entered into a draw
where 10 people will each win a prize of
at least
1.5 million
pubs are anticipating selling 21 million
fewer pints than normal over the
may bank holiday weekend the british
parents beer and pub association
said the lifting of all restrictions
next month is essential
for the survival of the sector the
number of smokers worldwide has
increased according to new research the
medical journal the lancet
says 1.1 billion people now use tobacco
products with smoking causing
more than seven and a half million
deaths
every year president assad will serve
a fourth term in office after winning
syria's election with
just over 95 percent of the vote
american and european officials have
questioned
the legitimacy of the election claiming
it was neither free nor
fair marcus rashford has said it was
surreal to get a zoom call from barack
obama when he was sitting in his kitchen
the two men arranged to speak through
their joint publisher
mr obama praised the footballer for his
campaign
on child poverty marcus i think is way
ahead of where i was at 23. i was still
trying to figure it out
if you give someone a helping hand at a
young age they'll go on to do
things that you know even they didn't
think or believe that was
achievable
love it and now you will remember
yesterday we spoke to david lofthouse
who has cerebral palsy he came on the
show with his friend jasper
to talk about their charity walk
yesterday while david finished the five
kilometer walk
in just under 10 hours
and he's raised over 18 000 pounds
for charity good on him they were
really nice boys yesterday two really
good friends doing this together
really nice to see they've done so well
now nato's secretary general has told
sky news he believes russia was involved
in the hijacking of a ryanair plane by
the bella russian government
jen stoltenberg was speaking as nato
began its biggest
military exercise this year he was on
board britain's new aircraft carrier hms
queen elizabeth of portugal which is
taking part in the operation as part
of her maiden deployment operation
steadfast defender involves more than 9
000 troops from more than 20 countries
including exercises in germany and
romania
belarus which has caused significant
international concern over the diversion
of that ryanair flight
borders russia and is just 550 miles
from romania
our diplomatic correspondent dominic
waghorn
has been on board the hms queen
elizabeth and sent this report
from the atlantic to the black sea a
massive military exercise
nato launching itself against an
imaginary threat
testing its readiness while its top
brass grapple with a very real crisis
over belarus
nato secretary general jen stoltenberg
condemned the forced diversion of the
ryanair passenger plane
what happened is absolutely unacceptable
and we have seen also a pattern of
russian behavior over the last years
but did he agree with the british
government that russia was most likely
involved too i think they are very right
to say that because
we know the very close relationship
between russia and belarus
and therefore it's hard to believe that
the regime in minsk
could do something like this without any
kind of
coordination with with russia
[Applause]
the comments weren't eased tensions in
russia's backyard
as thousands of nato troops exercise in
romania
and navy's drill in the black sea
in the atlantic britain's new aircraft
carrier hms queen elizabeth
is leading the exercise the aim of
operation
steadfast defender is to test nato's
ability
to deter threats and defend itself but
the exercise is being overshadowed by
this challenge from belarus
and possibly russia to what the alliance
stands for
there could be more friction with russia
and its allies as the queen elizabeth
strike group heads east
from this deck in the mediterranean
british and american jets will be
patrolling the black sea
monitoring russian activity we'll always
be keeping an eye on it uh
horizon scanning is is a sort of daily
um activity for us here just
understanding what the threats are
um and we have to be on our guard i've
said to a number of uh people today
miscalculation is something we have to
be really wary of
britain's first sea lord says russia
needs watching closely
russia is is looking to to demonstrate
what it might be able to do to us
russia's trying to demonstrate
where it may be able to threaten uh
nato interests and values
it's the queen elizabeth's first
operational deployment
a challenging debut for her and her crew
as they and their nine vessel strike
group
embark on a seven month voyage dominic
waghorn sky news
on hms queen elizabeth
now we've got a little bit of space
history to possibly bambooz bamboozle
you this morning a team of scientists
have produced the most
detailed map of the distribution of dark
matter
across the universe now dark matter is
not the same as
mata which is what we're all made of and
what our world exists of
but actually dark matter makes up the
vast vast majority of everything
in space so it's out there but weirdly
we don't really know what it is it's
exact composition
is still a mystery but there's
lots and lots of it
one day we'll find out in the meantime
we'll stick to some
real matters this morning like the
weather forecast morning now good
morning good news
we've got uh mostly bright and warm
conditions for the bank holiday weekend
until then though a bit of a blip cool
and cloudy for most places today
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning for this bank holiday
weekend most places will be enjoying
brighter and warmer conditions than
we've had of late in fact on bank
holiday monday
we could see the highest temperature of
spring so far on the last day of spring
in fact for the highest temperature of
the year so far
but uh before that it is looking quite
cool and cloudy for
many areas today from any central
western parts of britain as well as
ireland
there's cloudy skies a dull start this
morning quite murky around coastal areas
with patchy light rain and drizzle as
well and there's not going to be much
change in the story into this afternoon
these areas will stay cloudy but across
the northeast of scotland eastern parts
of england there should be some sunshine
developing and some warmth especially
warm
across parts of the southeast your
shower too may cross eastern areas later
though
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
thank you still to come on sky news
breakfast pub bosses say they expect to
serve
21 million fewer pints this bank holiday
despite the easing of some restrictions
details coming up
healthy venues including theaters and
nightclubs are
due to reopen on june the 21st but a few
minutes ago quasi-quatern said rising
levels of infection from new variants of
coronavirus
means plans won't be confirmed until
just before the deadline
we'll be looking at the data we've said
repeatedly that we won't make a final
decision about the 21st of june
until the 14th of june a week before the
the established date so uh i can't
guarantee one thing or the other now i
think we just have to look at the data
we've got to be patient we've got to be
very vigilant
people also have to be sensible and
absorb
observe all the guidelines in terms of
face uh
mask wearing uh social distancing
and we can't make any uh call one way or
the other
today unfortunately let's talk to our
political correspondent tamara koben so
data not dates effectively yes
absolutely and that is what boris
johnson said when he announced the road
map
a few months ago that you had to leave
those five-week intervals to see where
the data was leading
and the difficulty for the government is
that there's great excitement
about the reopening on june the 21st
people are booking weddings and holidays
and buying tickets for concerts
and so on but we won't know until just
before that
whether it's possible because as we
heard yesterday
from the health experts the number of
cases is going up a bit the number of
hospitalizations is going up a bit
and um many of those new cases are the
indian variant
quasi-quatern just told us that the data
is a matter of concern and therefore
they cannot guarantee
that we can get rid of all social
distancing restrictions
at the end of june as the prime minister
had planned
we've been seeing rumblings of concern
for the last few days
professor neil ferguson who does all the
the modeling
imperial college london he correctly
predicted how the kent variant
would pan out has said that it's quite
worrying
uh jenny harris from the uk's health
security agency said she agreed
that it was worrying and the next couple
of weeks will really tell
whether the government can risk that
level of opening up
at the end of june we we know from
all of dominic cummings evidence the
other day that we've seen this movie
before
and the government do not want to be
accused this time
of um failing to realize that the the
number of cases was a problem until too
late
okay tomorrow thank you well let's talk
to the chief executive of uk hospitality
kate nichols good to see you this
morning so i mean you're not going to
know anything
until at least june the 14th where does
that leave you
well that is quite challenging for
businesses obviously we have 25 percent
of hospitality businesses still closed
by legislation and 21st of june is the
first date from which they can open
so it is very short in terms of notice
but we do want to make sure that this is
the final
unlocking that we don't go back into
lockdown therefore we understand the
government needs to
to wait and see the data and get it
right but it is absolutely
critical for hospitality as a whole that
we do unlock on the 21st of june
so what happens if we don't well it will
be quite devastating
the businesses that are open and the
businesses that are trying to open
uh they ask that they're not operating
at a profit at the moment they're break
they're not even breaking even with the
social distancing restrictions
so the 21st of june is critical for our
pubs bars restaurants hotels
many of whom are still hemorrhaging cash
at the moment
even though they're open and will
struggle to remain afloat for much
longer and critically government support
for the sector tapers away
and starts to end from the 1st of july
so those businesses will
be struggling to stay afloat and about a
million jobs will be at risk
unless we can get government support
extended all those social distancing
restrictions lifted
but for those businesses who've yet to
open 15 months of closure with no income
at all
this will be devastating for them if we
cannot get them open on the 21st of june
i mean presumably if there was a delay
in full reopening you would
i mean you'd be lobbying for but you
would expect would you some sort of
further financial assistance
i think you would need to as i say the
government support
uh tapers away from the first of july
businesses will be forced to
choose between paying business rates
their taxes on their property
or paying their people and keeping the
business afloat that's not a position we
want our businesses to be in
and it can't be right that after 15
months of closure and heavy restrictions
that the government would suddenly cut
the industry loose
so we would need to have that extra
support extended businesses in scotland
and wales and northern ireland have that
breathing space they have a hundred
percent holiday on their business rates
until next april we need parity for
english businesses to avoid
many of them going bust uh in very tall
short order as a result of those
restrictions continuing
the industry can divide with those
restrictions i mean
you mentioned that a lot of hospitality
is is breaking even or
not quite breaking even at the moment
because of the the restrictions and the
table service and all that sort of stuff
which
which does make a big difference but i
mean for them at least
because they are pulling in some money
and say best breaking even that
that gives them a a little bit of
flexibility doesn't it i mean
believe me i know it's not a lot but
perhaps a little bit of flexibility
it's simply not sustainable for the long
term
none of these businesses are breaking
even the best that they are doing at the
moment is 60
of normal revenue levels they haven't
broken even since last february
uh when they started to feel the effects
of the coronavirus it isn't sustainable
to leave them in that situation for any
length of time even just a couple of
extra weeks
will be devastating for many because
they've run out of cash they are
existing on fumes at the moment
and the government support however
extensive it has been has not been
enough to cover the costs the industry
was hemorrhaging half a billion pounds a
month every month that it was closed
and yet as you said at the beginning of
this you know this has to be
a final way out of lockdown doesn't it i
mean you you can't afford to reopen
reopen and shut down again that just
isn't sustainable so it's
i mean i guess you must appreciate just
how difficult this is for the government
in coming to these decisions
we do appreciate how difficult it is
that's why we're pleased that the
government is working on data
on evidence um and that we hope that
that if the data and the evidence
isn't in the right situation there will
be evidence based in their support
package for the businesses
this is a difficult situation for the
government for businesses
and for the whole of the country then
you know the mental health and
well-being of many millions of people
who work in our sector
is also a part of this decision but also
we can see from the situation
across the country people are keen to be
able to get out
socialize safely again with family and
friends and hospitality provides
an important part of that so we do need
to make sure we get this balance right
and that we take a decision that's based
on on economics health and well-being in
the round as well as just the public
health data
and we all ought to have calls for
optimism because in this situation
unlike last december unlike last
september and unlike last july when we
did reopen hospitality
we have got a vaccine and we've got
large proportions of the
country vaccinated and therefore
protected so we should be able to take
bigger steps this time around hopefully
okay kate thank you
now it has been a difficult few days for
the government since the former downing
street advisor dominic cummings said
ministers had fallen
disastrously short of the standards that
the public has a right to expect
during the pandemic now his allegations
were serious no doubt but our vote is
actually
concerned ali fortescue has been to the
conservative heartland of colchester
in essex governor likes people spencer
doesn't
at the promenade petting zoo in malden
essex
they don't often talk politics they get
about
was it about 300 grams of insects a day
but this week you don't have to look far
to find a view on dominic cummings
to be fair i think what i know of him
from the last lot from the first lot
down really when he was like everyone
stay in
and everyone did abide and then he went
out and done his own little thing with
his family i think he can be a little
bit sly
in some instances and i don't think he
will trust him
to be honest and also think um
that the job that is being done is
actually being quite effective if you
look at all the statistics and the
figures of how much it has gone down and
how well the vaccine's working and now
it's going down to under 30s
i think we're coming quite far as a
whole country and
dealing with this horrible virus what do
you think of dominic cummings do you
trust him
not really he seems like a bit of a say
something but dude a complete opposite
and boris is quite an unusual prime
minister nothing that we used to do but
he seems to have everything coming to
control
at the start of the week polling
suggested that just 14
of people trusted dominic cummings to
tell the truth
but in tory colchester where the prime
minister came yesterday
there's been some cut through he's got
an opinion and he's behind the scenes
and uh is it true what he's saying i'd
like to know if it's true because
if it is were we turned over join us
join this lockdown everything is fair in
love and politics
there's not much point in playing a lot
of blame game
um we are where we are right now and all
we can do is just figure out how to keep
it moving
there is a political weariness here
people want an
end to lockdown they want to leave the
pandemic behind and no one is
particularly surprised by the chaos that
dominic cummings describes
at the start of kovid
mr cummings's verdict may not have
landed with everyone here
but a slip up now could be harder to
forgive
as a country strides out of lockdown
future freedom
still hangs in the balance ali fortescue
sky news
now time for the sport with jackie
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
many parts of ireland northern ireland
wales and central and western parts of
both scotland and england
will be largely cloudy and cool today
with patchy outbreaks of rain and
drizzle
however eastern areas of the uk will be
mainly dry bright
and warm pollen levels will be low for
most places today except for east anglia
and southeast england
where they will be at a moderate level
grass pollen season is in its early
stage so some symptoms may occur
on sunny days for some people but oak
tree pollen and fungal spores
are at medium risk the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
now matt hancock has denied lying about
protecting care homes from covid after
claims made by the prime minister's
former aide the health secretary said he
did tell downing street that all
patients sent from hospital to care
homes would be tested first but
maintained
testing capacity had to be built up
before it was possible well let's talk
to
robert kilgore the chief executive of
renaissance care which operates 15 homes
across
scotland and what was the situation back
in those early days
in scotland robert i mean were you under
the impression that
this sort of protective ring was going
to be applied to homes in scotland as
well as england
well we hoped um but um
i think we have to say first of all that
this was an
unprecedented and very uh
difficult situation for everyone not
just us
on at the front line and all our amazing
staff at the front line
but government ministers and
the scientists advising the government
ministers so it was an unprecedented
situation but it is a fact i mean it's
not rocket science i mean it's a fact
that nhs was put first and sadly
social care um uh came second that's a
fact
and what's the situation now in terms i
mean obviously a lot a lot of what's
happening now in terms of guests and all
the rest of it coming into homes is
is driven by by the scottish government
but what situation are you in at the
moment
well it's it there's definitely um a
much better
situation uh now i mean thankfully at
renaissance care um we had started
stocking up
excuse me with ppe in um
january 2020 and
um so we did not run out of ppe at
any stage um which is great but we ran
quite we ran uh short um
uh of some items in our back store
and there was quite a dunkirk spirit
about
we had people driving around uh
picking up ppe from dental surgeries
even nail bars
to to um restock our back
uh store if you like but at the front
line we never run out of ppe
um but yes i mean we all made mistakes
hindsight
is um as has been said before uh
a wonderful thing um but um
the fact is that um we could have
done uh uh things better looking back
and we could have um we made mistakes
and i certainly
made mistakes we made mistakes at our
company and
i know ministers both in the scottish
government and in the uk government
have made mistakes and and they have
admitted that and that's what
an inquiry whenever that happens the
sooner the better in my view
that we start uh an inquiry because
i mean yesterday's um uh not yesterday
but but
dominic cummings
appearance in front of the the two
committees
i mean it was a bit like watching a a
bitter
ex um sort of vent um uh
their views which which um was really in
my view a distraction
from the big picture which is what we
should be focusing on
and in terms of that big picture and how
it's obviously you
you want all the administrations across
the uk to be better prepared for this
moving forward i mean
who wouldn't but in terms of what you're
doing
to better prepare for the future and and
better prepare for your residence and
your staff what are you putting in place
well we we certainly um started stocking
up in january with pvp
we started staff wearing masks
first of april and we had our we locked
down our care homes on the 11th of march
um 12 days ahead of the government
lockdown
both in scotland and england it happened
on the 23rd of march 2020
um and if i have regrets and feeling
that we made mistakes i wish we'd
started stop wearing masks
on the first of march not the first of
april and i wish we'd locked down
on at least the first of march not the
11th of march
um and government certainly made
mistakes
um uh both in scotland and uk uh
white and they've admitted that and and
it's not we're not expecting what we're
looking for is
is honesty really um uh everybody makes
mistakes
um but it's about honesty and and and
that's what
um we'd really like to see hospital
discharges without testing
was a big um mistake and albeit
we didn't have the capacity to do that
and that
um there was a concern about nhs being
overrun
so very very difficult decisions there
and the other one which is as
important on at the care home front is
there was a delay because of the concern
about from the scientists
advising ministers in scotland and in
in westminster that asymptomatic
um uh staff in care homes
would not be infectious which obviously
turned out to be
incorrect um and so there was a slow
introduction right across the country
of weekly testing of care home staff
which
at the front line we've been calling for
uh
for a long time but actually it was slow
and in scotland it didn't actually
happen at the front line until after the
first wave was over
okay that we've only got 20 seconds left
but how are your staff
well that i mean the staff have been
absolutely amazing and thank you for
uh for asking they have been absolutely
amazing and they are the real heroes
from this and in 30 years of being
involved in the sector i've never been
prouder
of being involved in the sector they've
been absolutely fantastic
and we owe them a huge debt and i hope
that
we're certainly intending to do that and
i am i hope the government
uh don't let down the social care staff
both the scottish and uk governments
look after social care staff for the
amazing work they've done
robert good to talk to you thank you
thank you